okay don't you be looking at the
cameraman you're looking for a husband I
think you'll make a great wife
um when you meet the these girls let's
say in Omaha
uh are you more interested in meeting a
liberal girl that you get along with or
meeting a conservative girl that you
kind of want to hate [ __ ]
um I don't I can't hate [ __ ] somebody I
can't hold too contradictory things like
that in my mind okay like if I'm horny
and I get upset about something like I'm
not we can't [ __ ] all right so who are
you more interested in um I think you
get along with all types of people I I
like I I don't think that people's
political opinions have very little to
do with how they conduct themselves in
real life that was something that got
white from my [ __ ] mind over the past
five years A lot of my friends have been
like liberals I've talked to so many
conservatives that are like all my
conservative friends they all do [ __ ]
drugs they're all [ __ ] [ __ ] they're
horrible people on my Progressive side a
lot of our [ __ ] racist losers they
treat people like [ __ ] like I don't
think that like they're they're yeah no
your political opinions
I feel like it's more like your
personality traits versus like like I
get along with people that are more
extroverted too and just like more
similar like I find that that's more
um
you talked about uh like disrespecting I
don't but so there's this term like uh
toxic masculinity these days which I
think is just a great term description
I don't think I think there's just toxic
people I I think there's toxic women
that you should stay the hell away from
I think there's toxic men who are
[ __ ] idiots and cavemen you should
stay away from them I think it's an
unfair label
um there are traits that are unique to
men that get toxically exemplified now
such as
um like the ability to never show any
emotion ever and to be a stoic person
that keeps it all inside and like never
[ __ ] there's a lot of benefits to
being a stoic though
that processes and doesn't repress
everything yes but like you should be
able to have a I think that not being
able to have a conversation relating to
your emotions I think is a huge sign of
insecurity and weakness yeah but there's
a difference between having emotions and
being a human and being in an emotional
man you guys don't believe why do you
bring this up like you will okay every
time okay you might not believe us I'll
give you a little bit of credit okay and
I don't think Alex does I don't know
about you okay people will do this [ __ ]
where they'll be like oh no when we say
like don't be overly emotional what we
mean is like don't cry all the time if
that's all you were saying I'd be cool
with that but a lot of these people here
like if you ever show any vulnerability
to your woman ever she'll leave you yeah
that's true it's not but it's not like
it's true what like freshman fit says
that all the time yeah and that Hamas
guys
whatever the [ __ ] yeah yeah I don't I
don't know who it says what but the
message that I've generally understood
is that it's kind of like you just don't
know every woman's different and how
much emotion that she's willing to like
put like I want to say put up like put
up with differs on the women so a lot of
guys just say it's easier just to not
I I think Destiny actually makes a very
valid point here to be honest with you
there there's a fine line so I like
always using a one through ten scale
right 10 is being like showing no
emotion whatsoever I will never never be
vulnerable with my girl and one is being
a crying [ __ ] baby I don't think you
should be either I think you should find
a [ __ ] balance I think appropriate
balance is probably being an eight being
a man but also having some emotion
do you understand do you see what I'm
saying here and I understand what you're
saying but like the number is
meaningless that's going to be different
things to different people like an eight
for some person might be like the only
time I'm gonna cry is if both my parents
die within 12 hours or some people might
be like an eight is like I had a bad day
I actually think of one through ten is
very fair all I know is the men that I
respect the most in my life I've barely
ever seen cry
so but I so I think that a healthier
engagement with the question is I'm
gonna go back to the thing we said
before I think the confidence is the
thing that underpins all of it right if
I'm upset and you see me upset
um and I'm not playing League of Legends
it's because some serious [ __ ] happened
right it's supposed to be like the
archetype like Dad is crying that means
something really bad right so like yeah
like I think it's okay to get emotional
over things but as long as it's
something like series happened
um and I think it's better to be able to
show that and share that with your
partner than to like keep it all [ __ ]
bottled up but like if you come home and
you're like crying because you're like a
bad interaction with a customer yeah of
course but again the problem there isn't
whether you're emotional to emotional
it's like it's a lack of like confidence
that it's like showing like an emotional
instability I think which is the problem
I think it's ultimately because we
talked about the people that are saying
they should never cry you should never
do anything like that I think it's just
a backlash to basically what's been
happening in society this feminization
of men and men aren't being real men
anymore there is stats out there that
show like how men were more manly World
War II serving your country versus men
out there it's like there's guys that
you know Grand Grandpa died or like
almost died gave his life up in World
War II and you're crying over a video
game because you got shot and killed but
the the the the there is this like
coddling of young men today where it's
like the term man up they used to be
like yo man up now that's like you get
in trouble yeah but you're telling
someone I just think as women like we're
looking for someone that stays strong
when [ __ ] hits the fan exactly and it's
not to say that you can never ever show
any ounce of emotion but I just think in
general it's better to err on the side
of caution I I think we have to
recognize that where we were before was
unacceptable where we were 20 years ago
was not acceptable where men are killing
themselves at what three four five times
the rate of women where men are too
scared to seek help for like psychiatric
problems uh where men leave the military
the suicide rate gone down since I don't
actually know has it gone down since
like 100 100 years yeah I think it's
still higher for men um
so if like let's say one out of every
100 men committed suicide 100 years ago
is it two today is it
0.500 years ago why is committing
suicide I've been struggling in
committing suicide more than ever now is
that what you're saying no I'm I'm
asking the question but you said are
those the stats I believe it I looked at
this at what debate I did I think it was
like in the 70s it was like we hit a
crescendo with like the most amount of
male suicides and then it's gone down a
little bit but now it's rising again so
is that by the way is there we don't
have the answers here but is it is it
younger men no I think it's
it's people always think it's teens that
are killing themselves but I don't think
that's the case the bracket is around 45
yeah I think it's when people are
leaving you get kind of lonely you get
disconnected from the world and then
you're kind of like so I I I have three
things that are coming to mind here wait
before your three things I just want to
say before that like if we're gonna do
like male advice or male empowerment
like I I don't even use the term because
I know tricks the [ __ ] out of everybody
but like we have to be able to talk
about some concepts related to toxic
masculinity that keep men down and one
of those is the inability to process
emotions I'm not saying you've got to go
around and be like and I can I have an
example of what that means as in like
when you like here's an example okay men
cannot have conversations about their
emotions ever okay if a girl goes out
with a guy and she comes back and she's
talking to her friends right oh my God I
met this guy he was super cool he said
like guy will go out meet the woman of
his dreams go home to his friends and
everybody's like oh how was it and the
guy's like cool
and that's all he says right this is why
I like is there something wrong with
that yes it's so toxic because men
friendships suck we get so little out of
friendships and I think it's one of the
reasons why men are so desperate for
relationships with women and I think it
also ties into I think it ties into so
many other things it's one of the
reasons why I hear women will complain
that when they go on first dates with
guys they feel like they're their
[ __ ] therapists or their moms and I
think oftentimes because guys have
nobody that they talk to in their lives
about anything I think that's why I
would break up guys
another big reason is why like whenever
you see like breakups happen I've heard
a lot of red pill guys says women always
get so much credit when there's a
breakup and guys always get [ __ ] on like
they're always blamed but there's like
cheating going on women get so much more
leeway than men it's because when women
have problems in their relationships
they're telling all their girlfriends
about it like Oh My Boyfriend Does this
so when something happens yeah they're
way more ready to like side with their
girlfriend for guys you know again like
the woman might you know be [ __ ] like
cutting his tires every day before he
goes to work and you know guys like oh
how's everything going at home like it's
okay and that's like all they [ __ ]
say like our relationships are really
really really bad the way we communicate
with each other it's really really I'll
I'll use our friend Dave Chappelle as an
example here of a story that he told and
I'll I'll I'll give you my feedback he
says that like basically men are just
like black and white more rational women
are so emotional where it's like he
gives he did this a whole big stand up
it's like she's like so what happened I
met Dave went to the park punched a guy
in the face that's it I'm out that's the
man's story where the woman's story was
like well you have to understand that I
was on my period that day and she said
something really wrong to me and then
what happened is I was feeling a
triggered way and then what happened was
that then Sheila walked in and it's like
Jesus it's so funny I just want to know
what happened so there's two conflicting
ideologies on like how men and women
operate men from Mars whenever Venus
then that's just how men operate so
women they're always going to be more
emotional they're going to it's not
about the actual facts of the story it's
gonna be how they felt how you made them
feel and whatever like anyway but as far
as men go I do I don't like I don't know
this is I'm only gonna I can only say
what I know I have homies that I've been
friends with forever I could say
everything I want to them up to an
extent because as a man you know you can
give you can give your boys maybe 80 or
90 of the story and there's maybe like
10 of it you'll leave out because you
don't want to go
like you don't want to reveal too much
to the dude so I actually agree with
what you're saying to an extent meaning
if I had an issue and I was some girl I
was seeing I'd be like yes we went on
this date whatever whatever whatever and
I would be like we would have the
surface level conversation just to get
it off your chest
but maybe there's a little like you know
below the iceberg type of thing that you
won't reveal so I don't know if I buy
the the the notion matters I I well
right but I don't know if I'm by the
motion that men have no friends and they
have no one to talk to I I would highly
encourage men to have friends that they
should talk to but 100 it's not every
man there's some men who do I also have
really good friends I can talk to but
there's a lot of dudes who yeah like
Destiny is right like when they show up
on a date it is like a therapy session
because they've been they've been
withholding their emotions for so long
and then there's just finally someone
and they spent two hours just to
complaining to their girl yeah that's
the worst thing a guy could ever do I
know but is that you bottle up all your
emotions you don't talk to your boys and
you're gonna go [ __ ] blow it on a
date with a girl and you should be
asking questions but the reason is
because he has done shut up and ask
questions now's not the time to be
emotional and so I'm a girl you just met
right but the reason is because he has
no one he can share with
oh find a friend homie but part of the
emotions is not just being like
emotional like a woman and crying like
there's also anger that's an emotion
that men tend to have as well and if
they don't know how to handle that and
maintain that then that leads to them
lashing out you know making decisions
out of being at a high emotion and not
knowing how to control it so I do think
it is important that men do learn how to
master all of the emotions not just when
you're sad or when you're happy but also
when you're angry because a lot of times
men will be in positions with high
pressure
and if they don't know how to manage
that emotional time that they could turn
into a completely different direction of
where they were trying to go so I think
men expressing their emotion there is a
time and a place for it now do I think
they should be crying all the time no
absolutely not but there is I think
there is strength in a man who knows has
to handle all of his emotions
um because it's reliable you know as a
woman you're like okay he's upset he
knows how to be upset and recover he's
angry he knows how to be angry and
recovered so I think there is importance
in me Matt I have a question for you I
have a question for Nat because this is
the second or third time you've
addressed this exact same thing and I
think you're spot on
how are you so well versed at this exact
topic about a man handling his emotions
not succumbing to being emotional being
almost stoic playing it cool and if you
know that if Dad is crying some [ __ ] has
happened kind of you addressed how are
you so familiar with this I mean my dad
he grew up with all women in the house
so we had a lot of emotions he had to
handle and Not only was he handling his
own emotions but he's also handling our
emotions as well so his reaction to our
emotions it also does teach a man how to
handle emotions as well oh my God I just
realized something you have all sisters
oh yeah how many women are in your
Blended but in the household how many
women all women and then our little dog
Dante how many women uh three four
there's three girls and my mom so four
women and then our dog that's okay boy
gotcha all right forget about the dog
but shout out to him so it's your dad
and all women in the household yes
because I asked you how do you how are
you so familiar with this because you've
seen your dad yes it was a pretty solid
dude shout out to Marvin and he's just
there being a logical actor making money
successful guy and he's just dealing
with
I'm on my period about it and he's just
like stay calm brother don't freak out
play [ __ ] cool be a stoic and that's
how you learned about your dad and
that's what you learned about being a
man yes so
probably one of
that I'd also learn is that being around
women and their emotions I think that's
also a lesson for you to learn how to
handle those emotions without you
necessarily going through it you know
like you don't have to go through chaos
or a turmoil to know like oh my God this
is so bad they're like you can see it
and you can experience from an outside
perspective and learn and take that
information and and move with that very
powerful hopefully hopefully we're
listening I'd also push back a little
because people always say like women you
just want to push back on everything
how far up in the atmosphere you are
okay no but listen like the idea that
like women are emotional men are women
emotional okay men are emotional and I'm
glad she brought this up because the
anger thing is a huge [ __ ] issue okay
guys will say some [ __ ] like women are
emotional and then bump into a dude on
the streets of shoes and then somebody
dies like five seconds later okay do you
think do you think men and women are
equally emotional I think that it's very
rare that men and women are like equal
in anything maybe like numbers
by and large do you think men and women
are equally emotional
like I would say probably yes but it's
going to be expressed differently in
different ways so like men are probably
I think men tend to be a little bit more
extroverted in their displays of emotion
and women tend to be a little bit more
like in their head with it I think this
is a big problem when it comes to child
rearing when little girls cry the
teaching for them is like hey you're
crying why are you crying like let's
figure it out but when boys are upset
they want to like hit something you say
no don't do that so it's like okay [ __ ]
I can't have emotions as a boy right and
then we have something we carry with us
throughout like our entire life as as
young boys into adolescent men and a
young men into adulthood whereas women
are taught from earlier age like
processor emotions so it's hard to say
like who's more emotional because like
women obviously can express it in some
areas men can express in other areas I
think you bring up a very good point
because we all know that dude if he
steps on a shoe in the club he's trying
to fight you now but I feel like those
guys are few and far between and those
guys are looking for a fight and those
guys probably didn't didn't understand
like social dynamics and understand how
to handle their emotions as a kid moving
on
um the the topic I want to get into now
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible